hey this is
really weird video
of bill gates being interviewed by pbs
news's judy woodruff
um about his meetings and relationship
with the late jeffrey epstein
and bill gates
seems super nervous and when asked if
there's a lesson here
bill gates says
well he's dead
um
i'm not a conspiracy guy you guys all
know that you know i i'm not making any
claim about the circumstances of jeffrey
epstein's that i i just i'm not i don't
believe bill gates is involved in a
pedophile ring as some q anon people
like to say
this is just bizarre video of bill gates
seeming so nervous and uncomfortable
it could just be because he knows that
he had a relationship at least a
temporary one with a guy who ended up
being a really really bad guy
and then when asked about the lesson he
says well he's dead it's a crazy video
let's take a look at it it was reported
at that time
that you had a number of meetings with
jeffrey epstein who when you met him 10
years ago he was convicted of soliciting
prostitution from minors
what did you know about him when you
were meeting with him as you've said
yourself
in the hopes of raising money
uh you know i had
dinners with him uh i
regret doing that
he had relationships with uh people he
said you know would give to global
health which is uh now notice that gates
doesn't answer the question from judy
woodruff which is what did you know
about his run-ins with the law at the
time of your meetings gates just says he
claimed to know people that wanted to
donate but he's not actually answering
what he knew about epstein at the time
uh interest i have you know not nearly
enough philanthropy goes in that
direction
uh you know those meetings were were a
mistake they didn't result in
uh what he purported and i cut them off
you know that goes back a long
time ago now uh there's you know so
there's nothing new on that it was
reported that you continued to meet with
him over several years
and that in other words a number of
meetings
what did you do when you found out about
his background
well you know i've said i regretted
having those dinners uh and there's
nothing absolutely nothing new on that
is there a lesson for you for
anyone else looking looking at this
well he's dead so
uh
you know in general you always have to
be careful what does that mean i mean
genuinely what does that mean well he's
d what was the lesson to bill gates
about the fact that he met with someone
who either he knew had a background of
soliciting minors for prostitution
or and he still met with him or he
didn't know because he hadn't looked
into it and his team like either way
there might be a lesson for bill gates
but bill gates is like well he's dead uh
and you know the
you know i'm i'm
very proud of what we've done in
philanthropy very proud of the work of
the foundation
uh
you know
that's
that's what i get up every day and focus
on yeah so listen i i you guys know me
i'm not a conspiracy theorist i don't
think bill gates is involved in a child
pedophile ring i don't think bill gates
is trying to track people with vaccines
i think if every billionaire
um
behaved more like bill gates and less
like you know i don't know who somebody
else i think the we would be better off
we would be better off if that was the
case i think bill gates done a lot of
great things what he's been doing on
sanitation in africa
period it's just a bizarre interview and
when asked what lesson did you learn
saying well he's dead and you got to be
careful it's almost like it
is what's he saying what's he saying
about epstein or himself i don't
understand it it's very strange it's uh
sort of delightfully uncomfortable in
some strange way i'd be curious to hear
from you
what do you make of it and i can't
imagine bill gates looking or sounding
any more uncomfortable any more
uncomfortable some people are saying
well gates is just lying i think that
it's obvious that he's not answering the
questions being asked i mean the first
question is what did you know about
epstein's criminal past at the time you
met with him and gates says well i met
with him because he said he he had
donors for the things i'm working on
um
and then
when asked about uh
what you know do you regret it he said
well it didn't lead to any donations so
it's almost like he's saying had it led
to donations it would be fine despite
the criminal it's all weird i'm curious
to hear from you what you make of it